There are three basic checks that you
should make before releasing any app
that will cover the majority
of accessibility scenarios.
First, you need to provide
content descriptions for
user interface components that
do not have visible text.
This is most important for
buttons, check boxes, and
images because these components
often influence the flow of the app.
So use the android:contentDescription
layout attribute or
the setContentDescription() Java
method to provide this information for
accessibility services.
Note however that decorative graphics
are the exception to this rule, but
be sure to indicate this by setting
content description to NULL.Second,
you should make sure that users
can navigate your screen layouts
by using the hardware based, or
software directional controls.
Many users will employ D-pads,
trackballs, keyboards, and
navigation gestures, and you should be
confident that your Apple support these.
Put an exceptional focus on ensuring
that any UIElement that accepts input
Is reachable.
In some cases, this may require that
UI components are focusable, or
else you may need to adjust
the focus order to be more logical.
Finally, audio feedback must always
have a secondary feedback mechanism,
to support users who are deaf or
hard of hearing.
For example, a sound alert for the
arrival of a message must be accompanied
by a system notification, haptic
feedback or some other visual queue.